this is a low no she raps in Ukrainian
and speaks proudly about who she is and
where she's from but as most rap fans
will soon realize her life is far from
typical story a total idiot
what's the bottle keeper two years and /
- you probably have two leaders to go in
the sewage Ilona is a rapper carving out
a space all on her own
[Music]
- father I love my Lana
yeah your Africa now it's a sucre ma ya
him Malusi syrup alona's music has
received critical acclaim which is a big
deal because she looks and sounds
different from others in the rap scene
she's also one of the few female rappers
to rap in Ukrainian because most
Ukrainian rappers perform in Russian
[Music]
Krinsky movin my sweet vs. luck here
tsoukalos new be no great small dose of
anomalous vishna when I do a swatch in a
salon you mama a maniac or atticus
metaphorically War II Greenstein salami
frosting alone I didn't start at the top
or in a big city
she grew up in a small region of central
Ukraine Yama's rises for the 10 spot
Oona boys his skin
nandhu superhot adjust supermodel and
afterwards we let each care we let that
have sudah nepal ah it was in her
village that she first heard the music
that would change her life
yup was Neil Melissa's rap music lemony
blood vanessa talk money belly a
cassette or the mug would mr. Moussa
just me rocker would use me it done
waiver services kita which I lost look
at the Kahala Suzuki custom purchase not
good Ilona doesn't rap about fast cars
or Bentley's she raps about everyday
life and for her people
the villagers she grew up with her first
real hit was about fish literally fish
like the one she grew up seeing in the
rivers of her childhood the Kim the
skimmed little day in the suburb is now
a Muslim with millions of views on
YouTube and an award for best emerging
artists Ilona doesn't plan on stopping
anytime soon she has big plans not only
for herself but for her beloved country
[Music]
Zara stretches hibachi occasion otaku
cranes katratzi salud iki robe let
creative of reason extract little
community baby Meszaros do jurors
revised a new plan Jericho - mucho vizla
bhujiya coho spa do not see mislead
epitome Zara CSAP do me
[Music]
[Music]